en reconocimiento a su valentía frente a
la represión la unesco ha concedido este
año el premio mundial de la libertad de
prensa a la principal organización de
periodistas independientes de belarús
a veces se dice que ya no hay periodismo
en belarús lo que no es cierto
la gente trabaja allí redacciones
enteras trabajan a pesar de las graves
amenazas y la enorme presión a la que se
enfrentan
el día mundial de la libertad de prensa
es también un sombrío recordatorio de lo
peligroso que es para los periodistas
hacer su trabajo no solo en las zonas de
guerra sino en las sociedades
democráticas los reporteros se han
convertido en objetivos en la guerra de
ucrania en mexico ocho periodistas han
sido asesinados en lo que va del año
884 perdieron la vida solo por hacer su
trabajo entre 2012 y 2021 en casi nueve
de cada diez casos estos asesinatos no
se resuelven y siguen impunes
los reporteros sin fronteras ha
clasificado como muy mala la situación
de la libertad de prensa en un número
récord de 26 países
mientras que las democracias
escandinavas ocupan la mejor posición
iran eritrea y corea del norte son los
tres peores hong kong cayó en picada en
la clasificación internacional ya que
beijing intensificó la represión de las
voces críticas rusia también está en la
lista roja al intentar amordazar a los
medios de comunicación con una nueva ley
que podría encarcelar a cualquiera por
difundir lo que el kremlin considera
información falsa pero ucrania también
ha bajado en la tabla esto debido a las
intensas campañas de propaganda en este
país que amenazan la libertad de prensa